ich begrüße ich jetzt rege düring
vorsitzender der ads der
arbeitsgemeinschaft christlicher
schwestern verbände und
pflegeorganisationen in deutschland und
auch zugleich mitglied im deutschen
pflegerat frau göring
schauen wir mal auf die geplante
pflegereform sind sie eigentlich damit
rundum zufrieden das am hallo rundherum
zufrieden ganz bestimmt nicht wir haben
in dieser legislatur eine grundlegende
reform erwartet und das ist es jetzt
ganz bestimmt nicht vor allen dingen
haben wir einen weg erwartet in dem eine
pflegereform hätte diskutiert werden
können und angepasst werden können
aber wir bekommen überhaupt noch
regelungen die ein ganz kleines signal
an die pflegenden sind in ihrer oft doch
sehr schwierigen situation
was hätten sie sich denn mehr
versprochen sie kriegen ja moment jetzt
immerhin 300 euro oder die pflegekräfte
kriegen jetzt 300 euro mehr zumindest
diejenigen die bislang keinen tariflohn
bekommen haben ist das nicht genug davon
jetzt kann ja keine rede sein im
gesetzentwurf wenn er denn heute so aus
dem kabinett auch kommt ist festgelegt
dass diese tarifvertrags regelung oder
ähnliche zahlungen die in tarifverträgen
gleichen zum ersten september 2022 erst
in kraft treten also das signal an die
pflegenden in den einrichtungen egal in
welchem bundesland die nicht nach tarif
bezahlt werden ist das signal einfach
nicht in ordnung dass erst diese
bezahlung im september kommt und über
die tarifverträge hinaus muss sowieso
die bezahlung der pflegekräfte neu
geregelt werden sie müssen auch in denen
bereichen wo tarifverträge angewandt
werden noch mal ein ganzes stückchen
höher werden damit dieser beruf
überhaupt wieder attraktiv wird und man
in diesen beruf auch reingehen und
bleiben will
wir denken auf der einen seite an die
menschen die jeden tag sehr viel leisten
in den pflegeberufen aber auf der
anderen seite müssen wir auch an die
heim
oder denken und das große problem und
das ist ja auch beispielsweise die
kritik von patientenschutz verbänden ist
dieses gesetz diese reform macht das
wohnen in den heimen so teuer dass viele
menschen sich das gar nicht mehr leisten
können auch wenn es jetzt wie
angekündigt ausgleichszahlungen geben
sollen ist das so wird pflegen damit zum
luxus ja ich wohne ja nicht im heim ich
wohne auch in einem als
pflegebedürftiger aber das wohnen es
nicht der erste ansatz weshalb ich in
eine stationäre einrichtung gehe sondern
nicht jeder hin wenn es wirklich unter
allen anderen bedingungen mit ambulanter
pflege nicht mehr geht und meine
gesundheit gesundheitszustand so viel
pflege braucht umfassend dass ich in
einer einrichtung muss und dann geht es
um die pflege und nicht ums wohnen und
nicht um das leisten können sondern eine
gesellschaft muss in der lage sein den
pflegebedarf auch in einer guten weise
abzudecken
wir erwarten ja den nächsten jahren dass
wir noch sehr viel mehr pflegekräfte
brauchen
reicht dieses gesetz jetzt diese reform
aus oder was fordern sie damit der beruf
so attraktiver dass wir dann auch
wirklich weh mit dem demografischen
wandel der fortschreitet genügend
pflegekräfte haben also wir brauchen
einmal dass auch in diesem gesetzentwurf
jetzt angelegte stellen
bundeseinheitliche stellen bemessung
system ein erster schritt der umsetzung
da 27 jahre nach einführung der
pflegeversicherung gelten dann überall
in deutschland die gleichen
bemessungsgrundlagen für die stellen mit
diesem ersten schritt sind sicher einige
bundesländer dann etwas besser dran aber
es gibt auch bundesländern die nicht
besser dran sind oder
pflegeeinrichtungen bundesländer die
nicht besser dran sind
von daher ist auch dieses signal an die
pflegenden absolut nicht ausreichend
zumal dieses stellen wir messen system
erst im juli 23 dann wirklich 3 und das
ist mit einer der gründe weshalb
plötzlich viele pflegende aus dem beruf
raus gegangen sind oder jetzt in der
prämie situation oder nach den
erfahrungen der pandemie situation und
dann nochmal zusätzlichen anstrengungen
auch aus dem beruf raus gehen wollen und
sagen wir schaffen es einfach nicht mehr
erhalten das nicht mehr aus untersuchen
und zwar an
es ist das eine und das andere es muss
endlich geregelt werden dass in regionen
und innerhalb von tarifverträgen
die pflege fachpersonen ich sage ganz
bewusst fachpersonen und nicht
krankenschwester oder altenpfleger in
den in der langzeitpflege also in
stationären einrichtungen der ambulanten
pflege und in krankenhäusern gleich
bezahlt werden
es darf nicht sein dass man in der
langzeitpflege weniger verdient und ich
wenn ich dort richtig bin im pflegeberuf
nur wechsel weil es so nicht mehr geht
finanziell
das waren forderung von ulrike döring
von der arbeitsgemeinschaft christlicher
schwestern verbände und
pflegeorganisationen in deutschland
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
ich danke auch dass ich dazu stellung
nehmen durfte